and now to present the first award of
the evening here's a young man whose
Saturday Night Fever has become an
epidemic I saw the picture must have
been a bad fever several times they went
into convulsions welcome John Travolta
right here
hi thank you I'm very proud to be part
of this 50th anniversary and to get the
evening started those who have won the
nominations for outstanding performance
by an actress in a supporting role are
Leslie Brown Turning Point
Quinn Cummings and the goodbye girl
Melinda Dylan and Close Encounters of
the Third Kind Vanessa Redgrave and
Julia Tuesday Weld and looking for mr.
Goodbar and the winner is Vanessa
Redgrave
my dear colleagues I thank you very very
much for this tribute to my work I think
that Jane Fonda and I have done the best
work of our lives and I think this was
in part due to our director Fred
cinnamon and I also think it's in part
because we believed and we believed in
what we were expressing to out of
millions who gave their lives were
prepared to sacrifice everything in the
fight against fascist and racist Nazi
Germany and I salute you and I pay
tribute to you and I think you should be
very proud that in the last few weeks
you've stood firm and you have refused
to be intimidated by the threats of a
small bunch of Zionist hoodlums whose
behavior whose behavior is an insult to
the stature of Jews all over the world
and to their great and heroic record of
struggle against fascism and oppression
and I salute that record and I salute
salute all of you for having stood firm
and dealt a final blow against that
period when Nixon and McCarthy launched
a worldwide witch-hunt against those who
tried to express in their lives and
their work the truth that they believed
in I salute you and I thank you and I
pledge to you that I will continue to
fight against anti-semitism
and fascism